I understand you're familiar with the
layout of the shopping center where the
first attack seems to have occurred yes
that's right and it's been it's very
similar to most shopping centers where
you have a couple of flaws you'd expect
that the main trade brands if you like
of shops to be there and it's sort of
this is unfortunately remaining very
much of the Westgate Mall siege in Kenya
a few years ago which was carried out by
a group al-shabaab and you know it shows
you once again let's pick a soft target
let's look at people going about their
only business and and pick that target
on and I think this is an issue that we
have to look at and I agree with your
previous caller there but you know we
have to be open-minded as who is
responsible for this but it was look and
I agree with him
it's looking like an Islamic state type
of attack certainly fits in with the
Adnani
2014 fatwa that was given a couple of
years ago Howard knowledge being one of
the key and players in Islamic state of
course what we have some information
very mentions the Westgate Mall incident
shopping centers are a key target aren't
they for tax like this what why that's
why I mean I mean certainly in the UK
we've had the operation Griffin that
spread from the City of London is now
spread out throughout the whole of the
country where we've had private security
we've had private companies looking at
issues and of course we have that
practice session in the Trafford Centre
a few months ago looking at places where
you have these sort of large shopping
center areas looking at where's the best
places for evacuating people to safety
I'm sure this is an issue that the
German police themselves have tried to
address but you know you look at a
situation it comes on you straight away
and trying to deal with it and cost a
key part now for the per German police
at the moment and certainly with their
firearms upon discharge
minimize civilian casualties and to try
and bring this to the closest conclusion
as they can